Speaker 1: One of the questions that we
regularly ask each other, people call in,
they ask me. I asked producer Pat, you
know, we were regular. I asked guests,
are these lunatic conspiracy theorists,
particularly when it comes to the election,
the election fraud alleged of 2020? Do they
really believe it or is it just something
they say to show that they're on the team?
So when we see a poll that a while ago said,
oh, 57% of Trump voters believe Trump won
even though he didn't. We ask the question,
do they literally believe Trump won or do they
see saying Trump won as how they signaled that
they're on Trump's team? It could be one or the
other. It could be a combination of the two.
When it comes to Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell, we
now have a leaked test text message that tells us
he's a true believer. We see pillow come out and
say all these things, Oh, it's the machines. And
remember, he wanted to sue all machines.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Right. And we wonder,
could this guy possibly be for real? Well,
it turns out that on December 20th of 2020,
Pillow texted Trump Chief of Staff Mike Lindell.
The text message is longer than a CVS receipt,
so we're going to look at it in pieces. But the
takeaway is he really is a believer. Look at what
he this is not something he said publicly. This
is a private text message to Mark Meadows. And
Mike Pillow believes it all. It reads, Hey, Mark,
I felt I was supposed to text you this message,
you being a man of faith and on the front
line of the decisions that are going to be
historical, I guess he means historic. I would ask
that you pray for wisdom and discernment from God.
You are one of the people the President trusts
the most. That being said, I want to add my input.
Everything. Sidney. He's referring to Sidney
Powell, Trump's, I guess, lawyer at the time.
Everything Sidney has said is true. We have the
machines, and everything we already have proves
the president won by millions of votes. I have
read and not validated yet that you and others
talked him out of seizing them. If true, I prayed
is part of a bigger plan. This is pillow wanting
the voting machines to be seized by Trump. I
am grateful that on the night of the election
the algorithms of the corrupt machines broke and
they realized our president would win in spite of
the historical fraud. I look for deviations every
day in my business. When I find one, I investigate
relentlessly until I know why it happened and
how it happened. This is my gift from God that
has made my business so successful. He's a he's a
real believer. He is completely out of his mind.
He goes on to write to Mark Meadows from
11:15 p.m. on the night of the election. I
have spent all my time running impossible
deviations in numbers from this election.
What I also was blessed to be able to get
info and help Sidney Lynn, General Flynn and
everyone else out there gathering all the massive
evidence. I have been sickened by politicians,
especially Republican judges, the media not
wanting to see the truth no matter what the
truth would be. This is the biggest cover up
of one of the worst crimes in history. I have
spent over $1,000,000 to help uncover this fraud
and use my platform so people can get the word,
not give up, not to give up. The people on both
sides have to see the truth. And when they do,
there will be no civil war. People, including
politicians, are fearing the only thing any
of us should fear is fear of the Lord. Every
person on this planet needs to know the truth
and see the evidence. Mark God as His hand in
all of this and has put you on the front line.
I will continue praying for you to have great
wisdom and discernment. Blessings, Mike and
Mark Meadows responded. Thanks, brother. Pray
for a miracle. He really believes it. And the
reason we care about this is that it's arguably
harder to deal with people who really believe it,
with people who only say it. You merely have to
convince them it's no longer in their interest
to say it, but they already didn't believe it. So
it's much simpler and more straightforward when
you have a real believer like this. It is much
more difficult to disabuse them of these beliefs
and to deprogram them. And that's obviously what
we're coming up against right now. The kind of
silliest part is where he sees that there are some
impossible deviations, like as if pillow has any
idea how statistics work or any idea how to apply
them in the real world. But more importantly,
we still haven't actually seen any of the data
that this is supposedly based on. And that's maybe
the wackiest thing, which is going all the way
back to the beginning. Pillow has insisted we have
machines, we have data, we have all we have all
of it. We've run statistical analysis. Okay, well,
when are you going to show us the data? Oh,
I'll show it to you at my symposium or my
symposium, as he would call it. And then he didn't
show anything. And then there's been a year,
almost a year and a half. Now, if you have
the data, it would be great for you to show
it. It's always a week away from coming out.
My guess is they don't have it. But if these
text messages prove anything, it's that he
really believes this. And I think it's safe to
believe at least some portion of other
Republicans truly believe it as well. Sure,
some of them just say it. Yeah, Trump
won. Trump won. I believe that Trump won.
If Trump stopped saying it, they would stop saying
it too. But Mike Lindell truly, genuinely and
sincerely seems to believe this fairy tale,
and that makes it all the more difficult to
deal with. We'll have the text message. Up on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman show